you  we spend a lot of time in relationships  pointing out what's wrong with the other  person and insisting on our  blamelessness we imagine that's a good  strategy for getting what we want and  for being happy in a couple but that's  nonsense next time you feel strong  enough that you can for a moment stop  insisting you're always right try a  different tack out of the blue say sorry  I'm so anxious sorry I lose my temper  sorry I don't listen enough sorry I'm  too preoccupied sorry I both want you  close and push you away sorry are not  always balanced sane or mature you think  that might weaken you make you hostage  to the partners vengeance  it never does everything always gets  better from that point give it a try  sorry I'm so crazy  you  you